hey everybody i'm john luke and i'm
joined by jordan and phil and
collectively we each got to spend around
five hours with the avengers
beta uh before it is available to the
public for those who pre-ordered
uh later this friday if you're watching
this video at the time of release
we have tons of stuff on it i have an
explainer going up about
exactly how this game is structured for
those of you like me who just had no
idea how this game worked
uh before you actually got the chance to
play it but we're here to talk about how
it actually
feels to play so uh jordan let's start
with you
how did avengers actually feel to
control
so i was a little worried at first
because you get that intro level that
we've seen in all the e3
trailers where you're on the golden gate
bridge and you get to play as all
of the core avengers very briefly like
five minutes for each one it was very
streamlined very
holy handy and i didn't like it at all
but then they finally like gave us
control
and they gave us a few story missions
with hulk and kamala and then they open
it up even more and it's like here's
black widow and iron man
play a few more open-ended missions some
war zone drops etc etc
and that felt a lot better i still have
a few
issues and problems with how some of the
characters played
namely hulk but of what i played i'm
like okay i can
see what they're going for i can see the
game that they're trying to
create and it feels like an over the
shoulder
not quite arcady but similar theme of
like marvel's ultimate
ultimate alliance kind of in that like
field of game
the more time i spent with it the more i
enjoyed it like there's
it's it's melee combat in the sort of
that sort of vein that we've seen it's
like arkhamish
you know you've got your light attack
your heavy attack your counters you know
uh you've got super moves too because
you're a superhero
and once you get the sense of how those
things are supposed to work
and each character is actually a little
bit different they all have a little bit
of a different role
on the team based on like what their
abilities are
that didn't really come across in the
beta right away as not like a lot of
good
uh tutorializing for that i felt like so
once i actually got
to like kamala and until later black
widow and iron man and started to
understand like how they're supposed to
work
i actually enjoyed it a lot more like
iron man is a counter heavy character
and black widow is supposed
to be like juggling enemies and kamala
is about crowd control and like support
once you i love how you also just
skipped over hulk because
i actually i did start to appreciate
hulk but not at the beginning it took me
a long time to like figure out how to
play and that's what
that's kind of the thing you know like
hulk is a big tank that smashes through
everything which
makes sense but if you don't really get
what the hell you're supposed to be
doing it's just like you kind of just
you know swing your arms around and you
feel ineffectual
you know and it takes a bit to recognize
it like no
hulk hulk you hold down a button to like
use his special energy
and hulk gets health back every time he
punches a guy basically so your whole
idea is just
crash through like a freight train and
if you don't understand how that works
like hulk sucks but
then then you get the sense of it it
took a while to get there so like once i
i played enough of it to understand what
they were going for i really i
i dug it i think there's a lot of cool
nuance there yeah i think the game has
the most potential in how different the
characters feel
once you actually you know like get to
really experiment with them
you can play the whole uh game single
player like you can add like ai
companions
um i didn't actually get to try any of
the multiplayer with like other real
people
but i feel like that's where the game is
probably going to
actually shine the most because the the
you want like your characters to
coordinate with each other where it's
like okay like my friend can like fly as
iron man and like be like sniping from
above and then i have like
a whole kind of like tanking over here
and i have like kamala kind of crowd
controlling over here
you have to put a significant amount of
effort into each character
to like actually really like fully like
start to take advantage of them
even in the beta right like right you
would have to put a significant amount
of time
of like grinding just to like really
like get to like experience every
character so i feel like
you're gonna probably want to pick one
character and stick with it
and that might make the game i don't
know like
it might make it a little difficult to
like really like
get appreciate the game and like uh form
like a good
party to like truly take advantage of
like what the combat has to offer
you definitely have to put time into
each character to like unlock their
skills to like get a sense of how to
play them and make them cool
that's that's a big part of it like to
go to your point that's all is that like
yeah
each character kind of plays differently
but it's when you actually start
developing their skills and that's going
to take a big investment
yeah like just as an example like iron
man
starts with just his repulsors but if
you look at his skill tree he can unlock
missiles and lasers and each one of them
also has a skill tree
and use the d-pad to switch between all
of them and depending on how you switch
it changes his
heavy attack and how his like long range
attack works and
if you've just been playing as kamala
and hulk which is
what i did because those are the first
story missions that we get is to play as
those
characters when you get to iron man like
i picked up iron man i'm like well he
doesn't have
any awesome gear and he's still level
one so let me go to the harm room and
like
just grind for an hour or so just so
that he's on like the same
par level as my other characters and i
i can see some people not being
really happy about that it's kind of
weird that if you go on a mission and
you're bringing your ai companions with
you
they don't get the same experience that
you
get as well like i
i assume the game is just trying to
encourage you to just play with other
people it's like look if you want to
main iron man
main iron man and then find some friends
who went to maine
miss marvel hulk and black widow and
then just all play together and then
you'll just all just keep growing and
you won't have to worry about this but
i'm like
what if you don't have any friends what
if you're like jordan and you don't have
any friends
the the actual structure of the game
is sort of based around these repeatable
missions that you're doing uh outside of
like the story stuff
uh so you have like these war zones and
you have drop zones and they're
they're kind of meant to be these like
repeatable content
uh how'd you guys actually feel about
those as like
just do you think that is a sustainable
like you can keep doing these and they
will
they will be something you can just play
forever
yeah it's tough to say um you know this
is the it's the sort of destiny model
right where oh yeah you're replaying the
same content over again to get
better gear um and i feel like it's a
little too early
there's not a lot in this beta to really
get a good sense of how well any of that
will work like
the the war zone areas are cool in that
they're like
open they're like public event spaces
and destiny uh with a mission attached
so you can kind of like run around and
do other things find
optional bosses whatever as you are
going
toward your goal and then the other
missions are smaller and they're just
like
beat three waves of guys okay it's over
and there's
there's cool stuff in that i think it
can work um
i think it'll work better as we get
deeper into it and they become more
challenging
and like require more forethought on
your part to bring like the right gear
or to build a better team you know and
like ever
have people planning on what they're
going to need to do and what they're
going to need to have
i love the mission so you just drop in
and you just fight a bunch of bad guys
and you're done in like
five to ten minutes like i think it's
this game is at its
absolute best when you're just four
superheroes just
kicking a bunch of aim ass just like all
over the place like
that is it at like its very best when
you're in these more
open-ended environments where you kind
of get a little bit of choice and agency
over which
tasks you want to go after when you're
searching for loot or you're going after
a tier enemy before actually
doing the main part of the mission
whatever
that may be it's usually finding like a
shield vault and
going in and like hacking into the
computer
at the end like a bit of the cracks
begin to show up you don't get a lot of
the
like close range walls that allow hulk
to easily get around so it just
highlights the fact that he doesn't have
a lot of
mobility in comparison to the other
characters or you sometimes run into
like that really high tier
enemy and maybe you're playing as iron
man or kamala and you're like ah they
they have some pretty good skills but
none of them are like as
strong as hulk like this is designed for
hulk to
take on and so you run into a bit of a
wall in those open-ended areas where if
you don't pick the right character
you're kind of screwed
unless you're playing with a group of
friends and then like you
have like options and it's fine i think
now in the beta just because all the
missions are easy enough that you can
just kind of like tackle them with
whoever you want
but if they're going to get harder if
they're going to get more intricate
and offer a much more wide variety of
challenges which we don't know if they
will but if they do
it feels like this game isn't designed
to encapsulate multiple heroes it feels
like it's kind of like designed around a
few heroes and all the other heroes kind
of have
skill sets that best fit into the
control scheme as they can
i think we should note that you can you
bring ai characters if you play alone
on those missions so there you have a
team with you the whole time and it's
built for matchmaking like destiny too
so it's gonna
match making other people potentially
when you're actually playing it
wherein the the press portion of the
beta was i think so small that there
weren't really a lot of people around
um to match make in with so it might
feel a little different
on the whole part of what might make the
replayability aspect of it work is that
there it seems like there's going to be
a bunch more characters
so you know you might be running through
the same content over and over again but
you might be doing it as hulk and then
as kamala and then as hank him and like
so that might bring enough to it that
it'll be uh
interesting and exciting to kind of
rework
or you know fight those same fights over
and over again but with like a different
approach
yeah totally because the environments
aren't going to do that a lot of them
are very same
yeah same corridor the same
yeah i i think that's the thing that
makes me the most nervous is like man
these
these environments sure do look this
yeah
they're all the same aim bunker
basically but only in those missions the
story
missions actually do give you a bit of
variety in the environment
and then they help that the characters
are like talking to each other regularly
and there's
something exciting going on in the
background right jordan that is the
perfect segue
how did you guys feel about the story
missions
[Laughter]
i feel like the story missions they're
just in my mind better designed than
the repeatable daily strikes and
war zone things that you're doing like
they're designed for whichever character
you're playing as when you're playing as
hulk and kamala like in that mission to
go find jarvis
you get a lot of areas that are designed
for those two characters like move
around the map and you're encountering
enemies that are very that have a
playstyle that they would use against
you that you can easily
not easily but you can counter with hulk
and kamala during halt's level you get a
lot of like
bruiser enemies that are just like
coming at you so you can use like his
thunder clap and a lot of area of effect
stuff to kind of push people away and
then smash them to bits
and during like kamala section you have
like a lot of platforms all around that
you can easily
like arm swing to and then use her giant
like high five move or really long
stretchy arms and kicks
to like knock people off of the
platforms and like deal with them that
way so
the story missions feel a lot better
than the like
repeatable missions because they're
designed solely around whoever you're
playing as
in that story mission i think that the
game has the most potential right now in
the campaign stuff that's where it seems
most exciting um i really like
what they're doing with these characters
i think this is kind of like uh
following on from the mcu approach to
the avengers where they're you know
uh interestingly flawed characters and
there's they're not
they're often at odds with each other
and stuff like that like we start the
game with them basically disbanding
because of the a day stuff that we've
seen in trailers
um and then kamala is her role seems to
be like
reassembling them she's the force that's
bringing them all back together and
she's
super fun like she brings a lot to that
role
as like a super nerdy avengers fan and
she's just like using the power of her
fandom to bring them back
into the game it's great i really enjoy
that uh she's a good
she's a good every every person lens
basically for the avengers she's like
a great person to bounce dialogue off of
and she's funny
and she brings she brings our
perspective to it it's very good
like so i think that that's where i'm
most excited about the game isn't
playing
through that story content and seeing
what they do with uh you know
drunken he well iron man seems like he's
drinking a lot i don't know if that's
true
but like that's i think where we find
him and you know bruce banner is we're
like real mopey even more mopey than
usual
and uh and thor is there he seems upset
and you know like i don't know i haven't
got any sense of black widow in the
story yet
um but i think that that all of these
are going to be cool
um elaborations of what we've seen of
their characters in the
mcu and in comics it's a good new take
and i'm interested in it so
yeah absolutely especially because i'm
personally
wary of whether i'm going to want to
play this game as like a
repeatable live service type game like i
just don't know if
the structure will be there for me to
keep coming back to
and also i just don't have time in my
life for another game like that
um i play so much destiny at this point
i'm already like i should stop playing
destiny and
play something else you'll never stop i
didn't play until 2021 you're in
i know they add another thing and i'm
like i gotta
grind more crucible um but if this game
is like a really good
uh story that i can just play through
and have a good time
i think that'll be perfect for me and i
really like the characterization
you could tell they've put a lot of
attention and detail into
the acting and the cut scenes like it
it's fun to watch those characters just
talk with each other so i'm i'm like i
i think that i am totally with you phil
i think that has the most potential and
that is probably what i'm the most
excited for i am curious if if i'll end
up liking the game enough that i will
stick with it for a while i do think it
has a lot of potential
in its combat and in its structure but
kind of hard
hard to tell i think if the characters
are there um
combat wise it could be a game that i
could you know i might i don't know if
i'll play it all the time i don't know
if i have
room for another destiny either because
i do play a lot of destiny
um but i could definitely see like
popping back in you know playing
submissions here and there
with friends um and like really enjoying
it and like really getting into
a character for a while and then maybe
switching off into somebody else
and really getting into that character
and there's a lot of cool stuff there i
think
so hopefully it uh hopefully can
maintain so that's what we thought of
the marvel's avengers
beta you can check it out for yourself
if you pre-ordered the game
starting on friday if you're watching
this video at the time it's come up on
ps4 and then eventually
in the coming weeks it's going to be
available for the public
on other platforms as well like the xbox
and go check that out
if you want to see more stuff on the
game we have a couple of videos and
articles i have one
going up that's explaining exactly how
this game is structured if you're
somebody like me
who just had no idea how this game
worked before i played it
uh jordan also has a bunch of articles
up as well explaining
um how the progression system works and
phil has
uh probably more concise and better
written
uh impressions of this than this video
but
thank you yeah yeah it's fine it's a
video it's okay people just leave it in
the background they don't
you know that's what i do anyway
well anyway thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you